and we are doing this main quest now I
guess [ __ ] bed hey well we're
tracking this quest so let's I can do it
[Music]
other side quest
[ __ ] just run it back okay
ah shut
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
I don't know she is but she can go to
hell that's a shorty me that much
oh [ __ ] okay I don't want to do with
that big guys I'm go back up here I
probably got the controls back which I
had some health though omit i wish i had
somehow
Oh
now
yeah I is this oh Lisa my bad boy hurry
I don't know that shirt right there
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] me huh Jenna okay
it's an affair would best weight again I
know if sock in her eye this way a all
Lisa [ __ ] on the settle all right
[ __ ]
that's screaming
that badge
[Applause]
ok
I think that's trying to like respawn
it's been like that long there's a
church that gang can cut [ __ ] I'm
running bucket I am running what's here
honey I'll take that thank you
thank you hey there she agreed okay name
[Music]
that talk to him that's that one of the
sewer tunnels goes under the river it
leads to the other side wrinkly [ __ ]
which level needs to be lowered first
cuz right now everything is flooded
sounds like that sucks for you huh go to
the maintenance building and I can show
you what and how but you need to
I don't move as fast as I Easton I need
you to protect me from those demons will
you yes how can I say no thank you well
let's go then
okay one second had that phone kiya take
um that's where we're going with this
dude I guess right [ __ ] was she yelled
up alone [ __ ] repair my [ __ ] Jenna I
gotta repair my [ __ ] this guy can stay
here [ __ ] this guy's not waiting holy
[ __ ] okay how could I guess clear this
place out for him
all right it's this way yeah there's a
dude right there [ __ ] are you
looking at that sir aw can i okay my
dick sucked their [ __ ] die
look at that that's oh [ __ ] yes Stan I
got ya [ __ ] [ __ ] ya ha I like your
mother oh I got transom weapons there we
go
I really gotta repair my [ __ ] that's all
I gotta say oh thanks for waiting [ __ ]
you're waiting ah dang you know thanks
to the help back there hello sir
as 50
oh [ __ ]
okay so uh [ __ ] a backhaul now this
thank you yeah heck yeah oh [ __ ] is
going on over there thank God that way
[ __ ] that you ain't paying me enough
shut and I paying me enough
I think it will be best if we go
straight ahead yeah [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
yeah you guys in trouble stay close
i Josef let's do it yeah it was really
positive energy drinks
jet brah I think we should like get off
the streets see that greedy bastard it
is the end of days and yet he worries
only about making mom
yeah I could use a Bichette on
[Music]
[Music]
ah
and here
that's why Sam I see you doing [ __ ] to
this weapons all worn out and I chance
yet bets
a way of your [ __ ] front of me
look
yeah Rock isaza finally helping us
you
ok let's go Jess
Oh what the [ __ ]
there's more out there
and she gonna hold up or what
at
ok guess i'm just arriving say this like
this guy is like the worst partner I've
ever seen I get out I'm gonna have to
play with this dead again
got out chef I need this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah ash at pocket I oh [ __ ] i'm gonna
happen
okay well this guy's doing this I gotta
[ __ ] it up skills ok one sec
[Music]
[Music]
ok again
[Music]
[Music]
hey no
but i still have a mo for this yeah
we're here behind that door is the
entrance to the sewers lead the way
okay [ __ ]
can I need some lovin
the [ __ ] a weapon
hey
what's the quest now yeah well I guess
we finish that quest thank y'all